bears in control guys bears in control  and i'm not saying we cannot go above 87  i'm just saying that it's very likely  that we get rejected there all right  that we get rejected at 87 and that we  go lower all right this is the usual  thing breakout retest and continuation  so this is unfortunately the most likely  scenario now if we're able to ride away  today close above 87.  this would be a very nice victory of  balls let's see if it happens on higher  volume if yes  then we good bears and control guys  bears in control and i'm not saying we  cannot go above 87 i'm just saying that  it's very likely that we get rejected  there all right that we get rejected at  87 and that we go lower all right this  is the usual thing breakout retest and  continuation so this is unfortunately  the most likely scenario now if we're  able to ride away today close above 87.  this would be a very nice victory of  balls let's see if it happens on higher  volume if yes